Oh!
Welcome back to everybody's favorite game Devil May Cry 2!
Devil May Cry.
Well I said welcome back.
Welcome to...
Wait, did I say welcome back?
Or did I say welcome to... I don't know.
DMC 2!
You said welcome back.
Sorry, I'm so used to saying welcome back to a game.
It's been a while since we've started a new series, huh?
Anyway, welcome!
Master, Miss, to Devil May Cry!
Oh my gosh, so many people have been wanting me to play the series!
Since I'm finishing up some other series, such as Metal Gear Solid 3, Eternal Darkness we just beat.
I can finally start Devil May Cry.
Devil May Cry.
What does it say?
Really appreciate your positivity, patience, and willingness to engage with games as they are.
Warts and all.
It makes watching really enjoyable.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, I really appreciate you saying that.
Truly.
Thank you!
Devil May Park on!
I'm actually quite nervous though about playing this series, you guys.
I didn't try to read too much of pre-chat because...
This is my first time playing.
I will be playing in release order.
If you don't know that about me by now...
But you guys made the game seem so difficult.
I'm kind of scared.
And will I be playing DMC2?
Yeah!
If you don't want me to play it, you can just skip those streams, I guess.
So, yeah, I do plan on playing the whole series.
I already bought 4 and 5, so...
Wait, was there anything else?
Hold on, let me check.
Wait, Devil May... Yeah, 4 and 5.
Yeah, yeah, I already bought them, so...
Paragon, paragon, paragon.
Yeah.
DMC Devil May Cry.
That's the one we're playing today.
No, I'm just kidding.
I tried making that joke earlier in chat.
Well, I don't really know anything about the series, but my friend was just like...
You should tell them you're playing DMC Devil May Cry.
And watch them laugh.
And I did, and nobody got it.
And I was like, wait, what's so funny about it?
And they were like, it's just a bad reboot, question mark, I guess?
It's the Revengeance, kinda.
Okay.
But, like, Dante... Because they were explaining it to me.
They were like, imagine... Imagine you were playing MGS2...
As Raiden, and Raiden was bad.
And I was like, huh?
I don't understand.
The gameplay was good, but the story sucks.
Keith, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Will we watch the anime together?
I don't know.
Does Metal Gear survive?
Oh, okay, okay.
Explain it to me, like I'm a Metal Gear fan.
That's how I need you guys to explain it.
Place your bets on how long will Mint last until easy mode is now selectable.
Look, look, look.
Okay, you can't expect me to...
Okay, you can't expect me...
Streamer goes into game.
First time ever playing.
Streamer is bad at game.
VTuber, why are you bad at game?
First time ever playing.
I cannot believe you activated easy mode, Streamer.
VTuber, you're so... VTuber is so bad at game.
VTuber immediately get easy mode now selectable.
Because VTuber has never played game before.
Ever!
Enter goal!
Thank you for the 20 gifted.
Thank you.
Mito, did you get my super?
Your super?
Easy mode?
TMC, what is my favorite game?
I will try not to backseat.
Good luck.
Thank you!
Thank you.
So, I will probably be bad at the game, you guys.
Heads up.
I will probably be...
It might be frustrating to some of you that are really experienced in the game.
I apologize in advance.
But...
You know...
Hopefully, I'll get better.
You know, I would like to imagine I've developed a little bit as a gamer.
The first time I played Metal Gear Solid, some boss fights took me hours.
And then I had never touched the game again.
Like, Metal Gear Solid 3, I have not played in 2 years.
I played it for the first time 2 years ago and then I have not played it again since.
And then I was able to beat a boss that took me so long.
The first time, I was able to beat him first try.
I think I've gotten a little bit better as a gamer.
2 years is not that long.
For playing a game, I think it's very long.
If you don't play an instrument in 2 years, you won't know how to play it, probably.
I think.
Right?
The developer of DMC gave a PowerPoint about all the things they wanted to change about Dante.
Imagine if someone said, Snake isn't a silly weirdo, he's a badass ladies man.
He's that too though.
Don't mind the frustration, everybody needs learning.
Yeah, I think I have quite a bit of patience.
Usually.
Today I'm feeling a little off though.
You guys, I feel so terrible.
I feel so terrible.
I had to get some medicine for my cat.
He has a little thing.
He's had a thing on his arm for a while.
And the vet has never given him medicine for it.
But before it was kind of grown over.
It's like a... I don't want to call it a tumor.
But it's like a lesion on his arm, right?
And it was fine.
It was scabbed over for a while.
And then recently he bit it open again.
And so... Yeah, just a growth.
And so he's been biting at it.
And so I took him to the vet and they were like, okay, here's some medicine.
But he's gonna have to wear the cone of shame.
Actually, it's a donut.
It's a donut.
For a week at least.
Hopefully.
They said about a week.
And he's like... Oh my gosh, he's so dramatic about it.
He's like... Now he's walking.
But it's so pathetic.
He'll like walk to places that he doesn't usually go to.
And he'll be like...
I can't walk here because of this cone.
Well, it's a donut.
Thank you for the episode.
I can't wait to see how this VTuber gets motivated.
Thank you.
Yeah, he's being a real drama queen right now.
He's wearing his little donut.
And he'll like walk to a place and bump into it.
But he never walks there usually ever.
But he's like... Now that I have this donut on...
I can't go there even if...
I can't go there anymore.
He never went there before.
He's just being super drama about it.
And it's making me so sad.
What a stinky brat.
I know.
Yeah, today he wanted to go to that spot.
My freedom.
Yeah, he's being a little baby but it's making me so sad.
It's hurting my heart.
So...
Sword, gun, sword, royal, trick, gun, sword, trick, gun, royal guard.
That will maybe make sense to me in about an hour.
Recovering the voice by the way.
Are you ready for Vimeo?
I think so.
Actually my voice feels so much better.
No squeakies.
I think I'm all good.
Maybe.
But yeah.
Oh, that's CMC4.
Why would you trick me?
Okay, send that again in like...
3 games.
Send that in like 3 games.
You're a little early.
But you have the spirit.
I understand.
You're just excited.
I get it.
Okay.
Alright, villain.
I'll wait.
You better be a member until DMC4, okay?
Would recommend starting with 3 if you want brain rot.
How about I play until 3 and I still get the brain rot?
How about that?
How about I...
You know, because what if you told me to start with MGS3 to get the brain rot?
I still would have gotten brain rot starting at 1.
Don't underestimate my brain rot.
I still have parts of my brain that are available that are healthy.
You know?
I still have parts of my brain that are healthy that need to be consumed.
Maybe.
You guys, I'm so happy.
I recently bought another...
This is gonna sound so bad.
I recently bought another case.
Like a display case.
Just for Metal Gear stuff.
Start with revengeance, my lord.
You can't have any one brain rot.
Ryan, welcome to my bootcamp.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
So, I will have a display case just for Metal Gear stuff because I'm all out of room.
In my current display case, right now, my Metal Gear stuff takes up 2 out of 4 of the display cabinet.
It's actually not even a case, it's a cabinet.
Oh gosh.
And then I have no more room for my doujins, which is a really big problem.
Because I have 2 shelves taken up on my bookshelf by Metal Gear stuff.
So, I need all my Metal Gear stuff.
Right now it's kind of all spread out across my cafe.
So I will be consolidating it all into one spot.
Have you had time to build any Rex models?
No.
It's still in the box.
I'm looking at it right now.
Still over there.
But once I get it all nice looking, I'll take a picture for you guys.
You guys can see.
Hopefully everything will fit.
There will be some things that are too big to fit, I think.
Such as the Rex model box, but you know.
Please forgive my member chat.
You don't have to read this.
Wait.
I didn't mean a fence.
Why?
What do you mean a fence?
No, no.
What are you talking about?
Everything is all good.
Don't worry about it.
I appreciate apologizing, but you are all good.
Don't worry.
I love you, Momito-chan.
I love you, Koyu-chan.
Thank you.
You unlock a lot more space when you store stuff 3 feet off the ground.
As a DMC veteran, welcome to the series.
Good luck and don't forget to have fun.
Thank you.
Yeah, I saw a lot of people saying that they are very excited about this.
And I saw some people saying that they don't know anything about the series.
So, a reminder.
I know nothing about the series.
I know Pull My Degr- Devil Trigger.
I combined Devil and Trigger.
Pull My Devil Trigger.
That's literally all I know.
And I know Dante is a guy.
I know Vergil is a guy.
So, no spoilers, please.
Happy face of spoilers?
Yes.
For those who don't know, if there are spoilers in the chat that I shouldn't be seeing, just post a smiley face.
A little emote or smiley face, whatever.
And that will be my cue to not look at chat.
So that I don't see anything that could spoil the story or whatever.
I know everybody gets very excited about these types of games and it's hard to resist.
Just imagine Supernatural but more edgy and dramatic.
Stop!
You are speaking my language.
I love Supernatural.
I loved Supernatural.
I actually didn't finish it because the series got a little wacky.
But also I just didn't have time to finish it.
I didn't have Netflix anymore, basically.
But, that's not wrong.
I heard this describer by another Vtuber as cool boys doing cool things.
It was accurate.
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
Okay, should we get started then?
Oh my gosh.
There will be plenty of DMC brain rot in this chat.
Okay, good.
Express all your brain rot.
I'll probably be playing too much to re-chat too much but...
Yeah, okay.
Let's go!
Oh, that was my controller disconnecting as I said let's go.
Wait, reconnect, reconnect, reconnect.
Connect.
It says continue but I haven't started it at all so let's just...
Yes?
This game contains scenes of explicit violence and gore.
Devil!
Let's rock!
Wait,
what happened to it?
Why can't you see?
What happened to the game?
Give me a second.
What happened?
I think because it changed windows.
Windows.
Wait.
It launches a new window.
Yeah, I think that's what happened.
Sorry guys, you missed the whole intro.
I'm so sorry.
OBS, please.
OBS, please!
Hold on a second.
I think I might have to launch another game capture.
Let's see.
I got it.
We got it, we got it, we got it.
Okay.
Just a little bit of scope, sorry.
I think this is just... No spoilers, no spoilers, no spoilers.
Wait, how do I get out of this?
Oh there we go.
We can watch it again.
Warning, this game contains explicit gore and violence.
Let's rock!
Devil may cry.
Yippee, six months!
Thank you so much!
Thank you.
Alright, new game.
Oh my god.
Devil may cry.
This is the HD.
It's not original hardware, sorry.
Justice.
Sparda.
This is Sparda!
Why are you so quiet?
Turn up.
Sparda.
Where is Dante?
What about Dante?
Hot lady.
Oh my god, she is so Matrix coded.
Oh my god.
Devil may cry?
What?
It's a place?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
My door!
No!
Hey babe.
Oh my god.
You know, I couldn't be mad at her either.
Woah babe.
Are those my trophies?
Damn.
Dante-san.
My father... wait, my mother and my brother?
Woah!
Oh my god!
Roll credits, we're dead.
Oh my god.
We're dead.
Oh my god!
Sword.
Time to go to work guys.
Yeah, sword.
That's so old school.
Yeah, fuck around and find out lady.
See?
She got lucky.
No bullets.
I think you threw a sword at me.
Hot.
Oh my god.
Mom?
Not my mom.
Are you my mommy?
So quietly.
Thank you.
Mallet Island.
Ok.
I'm constantly having to adjust the volume.
I'm so sorry guys.
How did we get here?
Take me with you!
This really sets the tone for the whole series.
Oh my god, time to play.
Wow, we can jump.
Ok, so Y is...
Alright, here we go baby.
Wait, where did the sword come from?
Where are my guns?
Oh there we go.
Wait, I'm taunting?
What is this?
Ok.
Unknown.
I'm taunting?
Dante taunting.
Also thank you for the pink!
Someone sent me a pink super.
Thank you so much.
Sorry, a lot was going on.
I will read it.
I will read it later.
Can I go on top?
Alright, here we go.
Let's go.
Oh, what's this?
Oh my god.
You ready to make a devil cry?
Hell yeah!
Yellow orb.
A sacred stone that brings back life after death.
Ok.
Orb.
Pull my window trigger.
Oh gosh.
The way we run is a little special.
It's ok.
Go Dante, go.
Yorb.
Mission 1.
Curse of the bloody puppets.
Break the evil spell and open the cursed door.
Mission start.
Hello!
Oh these camera angles.
Ok, they are fixed camera angles.
Oh golly.
It's been a minute since I've done a game with fixed camera angles.
Ok, we got this.
It's fine.
I see Yorb?
No.
Rorb.
Red orb.
Red orb!
A red stone used to unlock new skills and doors.
Those are not the same thing.
Rorb.
To acquire new skills you must offer the stones to the god of time.
Pyro!
Thanks for the ticket.
Thank you.
Yeah, it does look kind of pink.
More than red, huh?
Oh, another Rorb.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh yes, not kidding.
I see another one up there.
Is that the god of time up there?
I'm gonna get all the orbs first.
Oh, I didn't even know there was one there.
I'm just that good.
Come on, Dante!
Slip!
No, I'm that good.
I'm that good.
I'm so good at this game already.
Nevermind.
Thank you for the superchat!
Can I, can I like dodge?
Can I like do a little...
The music is kind of wild.
Mint orb equals morb.
You can roll.
Okay, we do have a map now.
How do I get to the other parts of the...
Like, how do I go to item and stuff?
Okay, I'll just... Maybe later.
Sword... The bumpers?
It wasn't working.
Bumpers aren't working.
D-pad!
Ah, no, that's moving the map around.
But also, this is also the...
Gotta unlock it.
Okay, okay.
That's what I thought.
How do I get over here?
What do I jump onto?
Maybe...
Oh, okay.
Let's go, let's go talk to the time god.
This is a Capcom game based on Resident Evil, so expect puzzles.
Didn't some people say this was supposed to be Resident Evil?
A Resident... Not Resident Evil 1, but A Resident Evil.
Hello?
RE4.
Oh, this statue must be the Watcher of Time.
This is... This god knows...
And remembers... Oh, god knows.
And remembers all of the past.
This god knows... Well, what about the future?
I know the past too, because I...
I was in the past.
Anybody can remember all the past.
You're not special.
The words of this god are engraved.
Those who desire to acquire the ancient ways of war...
Shall offer the blood of monsters in exchange.
It's not responding.
I'd better unseal the door beneath here first!
Exclamation point.
Hope you enjoy the series.
Thank you!
Looking forward to the series.
Nice.
I'm exploring around first.
This is how we get over here.
Can I jump on to Angel?
No.
Are there any hidden doors and things like that?
Farron, welcome to Mambooship.
Thank you so much!
What's up there?
OK.
It's really... Oh my god!
How did... What?
There we go.
I was gonna say, there's really just only this stuff in there and I think I've got just about...
I assume everything in this room.
I'm assuming I got everything.
Let's go.
Yeet leap.
I don't see anything else, you guys.
Oh, wait.
You're about to get absolutely annihilated, nerd.
What do you mean?
Oh, wait.
I see a blue over there.
Yeah, there's the blue orb.
I thought I saw it.
That's right.
Oh, I think we have to go to the top and then drop down.
Blue orb, blue orb, blue orb.
Down, down, down.
Down.
There's another door there too.
Blue orb, blue orb time, blue orb time.
What does the blue orb allow me to do?
Fixed camera angles always confuse me when it comes to...
If I jump down here...
Dante, why can't you like jump and grab?
Grab the ledge.
More health juice.
Spoilers!
I'm just kidding.
He's not a parkour man.
You can jump against walls.
You can?
Oh, shoot.
It's the most generic hitting sound ever.
I wish I could see.
Oh my gosh.
This is the stream.
Yeah, me trying to get the blue orb is the stream, guys.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my gosh.
Come on, Dante.
There's like some enemy just watching him be pathetic.
Okay.
Wait, what's his idle stuff?
What does he do?
I'mma tired.
Do something.
Dante is so cool.
He becomes Ocelot.
Maybe I give up.
I don't know.
Come on.
Okay, I give up.
Let's just go.
First I want to see what this door is over here.
The blue door.
Over here?
Where was the blue door?
I saw it.
Or maybe I'm crazy.
Right...oh, there.
This door is sealed shut.
A rusty key may help.
Okay.
Use 45...
45 of them?
This is an expensive door.
What the hell?
This door is so expensive.
What is that?
A heavy iron lattice gate is lowered.
It appears that this iron lattice gate will have to be raised in order to get out of this old castle.
That's great.
Lattice.
These transitions are gnarly.
Oh, what's this?
Oh my god.
I think it's a little breezy outside, you guys.
I can see the castle's garden from the window.
I think it's a little breezy.
No.
What's this way?
Okay.
It's a puppet that resembles the residents of this castle.
This chapter was called the Bloody Puppets, wasn't it?
Are they going to come to life?
No, I'm scared.
Let's go.
Rorb?
Rorb.
I don't know how to fight yet.
Yellow.
I got the rusty key!
The key is rusted, but it should work.
Don't do it.
I'm ready.
I'm ready for you.
I wasn't ready.
Oh my god!
No, don't!
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh, not cool.
Can I use my guns?
How do I use my guns?
Oh.
X on Xbox controller.
Oh, okay.
Is that it?
Why is the combat music still going?
Oh, that's why.
Wait.
How do I...
Sorry.
The X is not working, so...
Come here, this way.
Right button plus X.
Oh!
Okay.
Thank you guys.
We gotta aim with R1 first.
Understood.
I did it.
Are there bullets in this game?
No!
This game owns...
Yippee!
No reloading or anything?
Unlimited ammo.
There are three openings to insert something.
Any hole is a goal.
Get in there Dante.
The mouth is wide open.
Okay.
Oh, what's this?
There's a ladder, but the lid is closed and I can't go through.
Lucky.
You can taunt.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
What if I leave?
Wait.
Camera angle.
There's more?
There's...more?
Oh my gosh.
There's more?
There's more upstairs.
I think.
What was the green orb?
The green orb is live.
Oh!
Missed the grorb.
It was...I didn't think it would disappear so fast.
Should I like go up there?
Oh my gosh.
Maybe he'll give me another grorb.
Grorb please!
What
am I hearing?
Where are they?
I'm gonna leave.
There's so many of these guys.
They're just never ending.
Let's just leave.
Can you stop camping the doorway please?
I can't tell if I'm hitting anybody.
OK.
Next one please.
Oh grorb!
Grorb!
We're important!
Important!
A secret stone that revitalizes energy as soon as you get it.
Nice, nice.
Anybody else?
Oh, I think so.
I'm just gonna pretend that there is.
What?
I hear them everywhere.
Did I go through here before?
Or wait, this is where I came from.
Yeah.
We got the rusty key, so let's go.
They're in the walls.
Wait,
actually...
Birthday?
So happy minty...Vince...Vince playing one of my favorite games of all time.
I turned 30 yesterday.
Could I please get a happy birthday minto?
Sideswipe!
Happy birthday!
Yay!
I used the rusty key.
Let's go.
This guy looks suspicious.
Good.
If I attack first...
I see them.
I see them all.
Oh gosh.
Aim Dante, just look up.
Oh my gosh, gamers don't look up you guys.
No!
Dante look up!
There is something written.
The 17 puppets are my masters.
There will be no admission as long as my masters are here.
What the hell?
OK.
He is too cool to look up to anything.
OK, 17 puppets.
Are we gonna die?
Question, how do I save?
Oh, RV.
Current mission.
How do I save?
You don't?
Saving is per mission.
Save at the time statues.
You guys are such liars!
Oh, wait.
Does it do the thing where...
It looks like it starts you at the beginning of the chapter.
Is it one of those where it starts you at the beginning of the mission kind of dealio?
Oh, the music stopped.
I was gonna say, I don't think they like that very much.
Oh, we are gonna go on top of a plane.
Oh, blue.
Nice.
Blorb!
Let's get this party started.
Also known as the fragment of life.
But it's only one fourth of the whole piece.
When it becomes whole, it will have the power to increase the vitality's maximum.
Can I?
Dang it.
Come on Dante.
Dante, aim!
Wait, there is only three guys here.
17 my butt.
Come on.
Wait, look this way.
Can I go down any further?
Oh my god.
No, that's so impossible.
They are right there.
Can I slice them, dice them?
Can I slice off their little...
Come down.
I didn't even reach that one.
Alright, come on.
Guys, come down.
You can come down.
Oh.
What are you trying to do?
You missed.
What is this?
This emblem responds to my powers.
That's my power.
Devil arms.
Handgun.
Ebony and ivory.
Dante's handmade guns.
You can select your devil trigger item.
Use your sword.
Okay.
Alright, smarty pants.
Oh, I see.
It's lighting up.
Maybe you were on to something for real.
Oh.
It's a one way road.
Oh my gosh.
Oh shoot.
No, no, no.
Stay away.
Oh my gosh.
GORB!
Got it.
Oh, they are coming from all sides.
Okay, I love that.
I love that part.
Stay away from me!
Oh, ouchie, ouchie, ouchie.
Oh my gosh, how do I dodge?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Take that.
I'll take that.
Uh oh.
What does that mean?
Is it over here?
Did I grab everything?
I think so.
Okay.
R1A.
Oh, R1.
Sorry.
No.
Oh my gosh.
Turn around.
Chill
here.
Be safe.
Anybody?
That was close.
Nice.
Gun only run.
I used my sword like once.
Collect.
Collect little rorbs.
Rorb collector.
Perfect.
Is that it?
Rorbs.
125.
Okay.
Nice.
C!
C for cool.
C for...
Could you do that?
C for cute.
No.
Dante is cool.
He's not cute.
Clear!
Awesome.
Alright.
Next mission.
So this is how the whole thing... How many missions are there then?
Open the door of the cathedral.
Wait.
Power up.
You can acquire health, magic and other enhancement items.
Devil star.
I was hoping everything would be called devil something.
20-ish missions?
Okay.
A rare stone that vitalizes.
I see their costs.
Wait, this one is free.
Maybe?
5 devil trigger gauges.
Wait, what does that mean?
Permanent upgrades to your character are almost always better than consumables.
So like this... Wait.
So these are considered consumables.
And are these... Wait.
No, that's a consumable too.
Holds power to eliminate all evil that's around you.
Woah.
Blorb and porb are upgrades.
Increase the maximum number of your devil trigger gauges.
So... Wait, can I buy this?
No.
I can't apparently buy anything.
That's okay.
That's fine.
Judge of death.
Oh, okay.
Oh my
god.
Behind me!
There you are.
I hear them.
I hear them in the walls.
Oh my god, they sound sick.
Hello?
Oh, there they are.
Ouch!
Oh my gosh.
Holy cow!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die for real.
Wait, can I get a gorb, please?
Can I get a gorb, please?
No?
Rude!
I died.
Wait, what do you mean only... Wait, what do you mean four yellow orbs?
Wait, what do you mean by that?
What do you mean by that?
If I run out...
Oh my god, wait.
Hold on.
Please, I was not ready.
I was not ready!
Oh, this guy is here.
I'm gonna go in here.
Nice.
Oh, hello.
Okay, I can do power-ups here and stuff.
Interesting.
Okay.
Oh, my bad.
Many of the books are records of the past civil court hearings and the rest are records of the harvest and births.
Books!
Is this a door?
No.
Can I destroy this?
What can I destroy?
Let's go.
I hate furniture.
I can't destroy the books though.
We cannot destroy the books, those are...
They come back!
They come back.
Understandable.
I got it.
I learned.
Get him first.
Get him while he's down, Dante.
That's just called being smart.
Being preemptive.
You know, you get the first attack on them and everything.
Okay.
Oh gosh, you guys.
I don't wanna die again.
I'm scared of them launching at me like they did before!
Maybe we're in a better spot now.
Okay.
What changed?
Dante is not smart, he's cool.
Yeah, it's not cool to be smart.
What's this?
There's a painting of a middle-aged man.
Riveting.
That is not a middle-aged man!
I know my head is kind of blocking it, but like...
What?
That is not... that's not a middle-aged man.
Okay.
I don't wanna go in there quite yet.
I do wanna go up a little bit.
Oh, this looks...
Well, the other door looks way more official.
What's this?
There's a sculpture of a female in agony with a sword pierced through her chest.
Wait, I can hear a voice.
I am Alistair.
The weak shall give their heart and swear their eternal loyalty to me.
Am I dead?
No.
Twitchy.
Why does this keep happening to me?
Oh my god.
Oh...
But how did you... wait.
That would like go through your face Dante.
This isn't even my sword.
I have the power!
Oh my god.
He's not even doing this for anyone.
Just himself.
Alistair gives the possessor lightning speed and aerial capabilities!
I'm interested in how his jacket is holding up, right?
Wait, so can I...
Weapon.
Wait.
Oh, hold on.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Oh, it's already... OK, it's already equipped.
OK, just kidding.
Pizza Man Adventures.
And also, wait, what is the blue... there's like little blue barks.
Thanks!
I don't understand...
I don't understand yet, but maybe I'll understand.
This door is locked... oh, wait.
Looks like a rusty key.
OK.
One combo I like with sword is Y-Y-Delay-Y-Y-Y.
Oh, thanks, I'll try.
TMC was a prototype branch for RE4.
Dante is basically Leon.
I can see... I can feel how this is Resident Evil, you know.
Obviously, just because of the camera angles alone make it very Resident Evil.
OK.
I hate Mother Nature.
ViviCorn, thanks for the gifted!
Why do you keep changing your profile picture like every two days?
I don't recognize you anymore.
What's this?
Can I power up?
Like, if I hold it?
No.
Uhm...
OK...
What's over here?
Watson?
Albin!
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
Thank you!
Oh, what's that?
What's this?
How do I grab...
A shotgun!
OK...
Wait, what if I shoot it with the shotgun?
Oh, sorry.
I keep pressing B because, like, I'm so used to...
JP games where...
B is...
Like, well, rather it's circle.
And so it's like...
Select.
Equip?
Yes.
Nothing.
How fast...
Oh my god!
OK, so...
How was I able to shoot?
Sorry, I'm just testing it right now.
OK.
It's pretty fast!
It's actually really fast!
Way faster than I thought.
Man, I love Minto!
Nisox, thank you!
Thanks for 6 months!
Oh my gosh, it really has been half a year.
Try holding the fire button.
Oh!
For shotgun.
Oh,
I think I'm stupid.
Mako, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Thank you so much!
Grim Reaper like devil is depicted.
The key is embedded.
Should I take it?
Yes.
Rest the key.
Alright, prepare to be ambushed.
Ambush?
DMC1 is rough but fun.
All good!
Thank you though.
At least I'm not so inexperienced with older games, you know?
Especially older... I don't want to say janky games, but like, you know what I mean.
Alright, here we go.
Oh!
Yeah,
you're gonna... you're gonna hurt me.
You're gonna come at me now?
Chill out!
Oh my god!
No!
They're coming from the walls!
That's right!
Oh my gosh, how did I dodge that?
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Yeah, yeah!
Grab their... grab their Orbeez.
Oh my gosh.
I don't even know who I'm hitting!
Everybody's dead!
Everybody dies!
Are these eternal?
Do these ever stop?
Please!
Give me a rest!
Dante is tired!
They never die, real.
Just keep blasting.
Anyway...
These guys
are crazy!
They take forever.
Oh, we lived!
Let's go!
Press LB?
Oh, what's that do?
Shotgun!
Paragon!
I just blasted.
Sorry guys, you might be like shouting things at me, but I'm not looking at chat, so...
I'm playing a game.
Sorry.
Where's the key?
Busy room.
Oh my gosh.
Oh,
sometimes they stay away, sometimes they don't.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, cinematic.
This angle is so...
This angle is so cinematic.
Oh my gosh, I did the wrong thing.
Stop shooting me!
I mean...
Wow, nice parry.
Let's go.
I like combining them, you know?
To keep them away from me.
Die!
Is the devil trigger what I just did?
Did I just pull my devil trigger?
Let's go!
Is that...oh, hold on.
Wait, will it show up?
I was hoping it would show up if I...the little blue things on the...
Or is that the blue orbs that I'm picking up?
When it shows my health bar, you know?
It's mana.
Oh, ok, ok, ok.
Nice.
Let's see what we got around here.
Charge is up in 5.
Oh, come on.
Go away.
It's a statue of an angel.
The guardian of a god.
What's this?
It's an engraving of a lion.
There's something written.
Only those who the lion has accepted can set me free.
That's my best lion roar.
Do you accept me, lion?
The yeet jump is so funny.
What is here?
Oh my
god, there's so many guys!
Where is swordsman?
Where is swordsman real?
What the hell is this?
Stylish.
Great job, Minto.
Thank you!
I swallowed my drink wrong.
There's something written.
A god stands before thee.
It's me, Minto.
To open the path, use thy strength to drive it back.
I am the god.
Wait, I'm trying to attack this angel.
There's gotta be something in there.
She's beginning to believe.
I'm starting to get it, I think.
I hope.
There's something engraved beneath the opening.
This is where the guiding souls gather.
Like, I have no idea what's going on, but I'm enjoying myself.
Oh my gosh, I really swallowed that wrong.
Do I go through here or do I go back to the lion?
Let's go through here.
Staff of Judgment.
A staff that shines with mysterious light.
I have to not get crushed.
Nevermind.
He's judging me, you guys.
Wait, is it a weapon?
No.
Memento of Dante's mother.
In the back is an engraving, Virgil and Dante!
Is Virgil my brother?
The nostalgia of seeing this game again reminds me of why I love this game so much.
This game always holds a special place in my heart.
Wait, what's the vital star?
Oh, this is the revitalizer.
Oh.
No, no, no.
I don't need it.
Oh!
We ended up back here!
Wait, how did I get to the...
To the pool.
Was it here?
What the?
What is this?
Huh?
Oh!
This is like Dementors!
What's going on?
Oh?
Oh my god.
Oh, they...avoid...
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my god.
I
don't think we're good.
Oh wait, maybe we are good.
Oh, we're good!
Okay!
Anyway...
Is there anyone else up here?
Am I crazy?
Did I know those ghosts?
Just because I'm a ghost doesn't mean I know every ghost.
Her sword is a tool of judgment.
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
Crash!
Wait, am I going the wrong way?
I can't remember which way...
Nice.
A raid of spiders!
Oh no, we went through this door down here.
Here.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now I have the judgment thing, so the...
Oh gosh.
If I could reach, that would be awesome.
Oh my god.
Ouchie, ouch, ouch.
Kill that guy.
He attacked me and hurt me.
You hurt me good.
Get the corp.
Keep my distance.
I guess this would be a good time to use this, huh?
Yeah, yeah.
I did it.
Oh, worm.
Okay, so what's this guy over here?
It's a statue of an angel.
Oh, a guardian of God.
Maybe I bring the judgment... Okay, lion.
Come judge me.
Ouch!
Okay, just kidding.
There's an immense power that will not allow anyone to get closer.
Before I can confront the lion, I'll need a sign.
A sign?
Give me a sign.
God, are you there?
God, give me a sign.
Oh, come on.
So if you're just hanging out in an area for too long, the guys will come out?
What do I do here, though?
That was so intense.
I'm trying to destroy the fountain.
Won't let me, though.
I just went... Oh wait, there was a hole.
Hold on, there was like more stuff.
There was more stuff in the other room.
I just didn't go to it.
I don't think I can go from there.
I think I have to go around.
Dante, best boy.
Stay away from me.
You freak.
Stay away from me, you freaks.
You freaks.
Stay away.
Oh my gosh.
Too many of you guys.
I don't want to deal with you.
Leave me alone.
Devil trigger time.
So this thing is where all the souls gather.
Whatever that means.
Uh...
I whack it.
Okay, nevermind.
This is where we went down.
There were no other doors, right?
No?
Go back to where you got the sword, Minto.
Where was...
Oh, I know where that was.
Go back to where I got the sword.
Okay.
I'll go.
Oh
my god.
Oh my god.
I didn't even see this guy here.
Holy moly.
Oh my gosh.
I didn't even see them here.
That's right.
I can't see.
Go away.
Get out of my face.
Give me some space.
The social distancing.
Oh my gosh.
How did I...
Out, out, out, out.
Out.
I tried to shoot him, but I didn't get to...
Restore, restore.
Restore, restore, restore.
There are so many guys.
Okay, so here.
Anyway, I started blasting.
Take that.
The wall.
So here.
This is where I died.
Give me a sign.
Down this way?
There is another door down here.
Was there?
Did I go down here?
Oh my gosh.
And...
Stupid wall ghost.
This makes me want to get some scissors though.
It's kind of cool.
I like it.
It's a good image, I think.
What is this?
Oh, oh wait.
It's a landscape painting.
Oh, there is an Iris Aura surrounding it.
I remember.
Is there another guy?
Oh, there is two of them.
Ah!
I wish I could use my sword on them, but...
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, take that and...
There is three of them!
There is three of them.
Take that wall.
If I blow up the wall enough, he can't hide in there, you know?
You can use the sword after the shot, I guess?
But he is like in the wall, so...
It's all good.
Is there another one?
Oh my god.
Leave me alone!
You can combo your weapons together.
Okay, hold on.
Let me try it.
Oh my gosh!
He dodged it though.
Am I just bad?
Oh my god, go away!
Wait, this door...
Led to...
This room.
I don't...Wait, can I get a hint?
What am I supposed to do?
I got that staff.
Go back to where you got Alistair.
I was literally just there!
Was I not in the right place?
Spider wall is a door.
Oh my god.
No.
No, please.
Please.
Please don't let me die.
I don't wanna die yet.
Please.
Oh my god.
Everybody is back.
Everybody is here.
Spider wall is a door now.
Was it not a door before?
Wait, the door I went through.
Farming orbs.
Wait, so we went through that obviously.
This was always a door.
There's...
Interact with the white wall.
This wall?
This wall.
It's a carving of the judge of death.
Is he gonna judge me?
It looks like the judge should be holding something.
I saw Charlotte use the staff of judgment.
Yes.
I see.
That was mission clear the whole time!
Same.
The spiders were supposed to lead you there.
I was just like squish squash.
Nice.
Clear.
Oh, no.
Oh, easy automatic...
I only died once.
What are you talking about game?
It's because I took too long.
I was farming.
What are you talking about?
Wow.
In this mode you'll be able to perform and enjoy...
You can't blame me.
I was so focused on the lion.
With just one button you'll be able to perform many different sword actions.
It sounds awesome though.
No.
Overcome the trial and acquire the pride of lion.
Now we're on to the lion, guys.
We're finally there.
Stinger level 1.
With lightning speed, plunge the sword into enemies.
We can do this one.
Become airborne and be capable of performing aerial electrocution attacks.
I can afford it.
But I can only get stinger or air raid.
We love stinger.
Always get stinger.
Stinger is broken.
Stinger is OP.
Okay.
I'll trust you guys.
Plunge the sword from an even further distance.
What other extra stuff can I get?
I can get blue orb.
I can't get purple orb.
I can get blue orb though.
I'm going to get it.
See?
It was so worth it.
We wouldn't have been able to get both stuff, you guys.
Gosh.
That's why I farmed.
Stinger, my beloved.
What's wrong with this?
Is it me?
Or does that thing up there look kind of sexy?
It looks like... Okay, you see?
It looks like it's a lady being like...
And her legs are kind of like...
They're crossed in front of each other and her arms are out.
The walls are sexy.
The pride of lion is granted only to those who choose the path of trials.
It was a trial to get here so I think I deserve this.
I think I've earned this.
Thank you.
Can the wall attack me with the hand?
It was a trial to get here.
Please, lion.
Oh my gosh.
See?
It's so sexy though.
It's not just me, right?
You guys see it too, right?
What's this?
This symbol resembles the staff of Hermes.
It's used in the art of alchemy.
I can feel some kind of mysterious force but I just can't quite understand it.
The walls are sexy.
Mito, true enjoyer of architecture.
It is super just you, chief.
No, no, no, no.
I know it's not just me.
It states go back the path and thou shalt return from the abyss.
With thy lion heart and thou shalt receive the pride of lion.
Ok.
Wait, the path?
This way?
I don't think so.
The music just looped.
Can I not jump into this?
It looks like a portal.
Ok, I'm going back.
Easiest trial ever!
What the hell is this?
Skellies!
Happy Halloween!
My health.
Use stinger?
I just got it.
How do I use it?
Nice.
I'll take that.
I love how people are like...
Hey Vtuber, do this thing when there is literally no tutorial on how to do anything in this game.
It didn't even teach me how to shoot.
Do you know fighting game inputs?
No!
Sign of the strong.
It allows confrontation with the lion gatekeeper.
Alright.
Sword,
what's wrong?
Are you not happy with...
That's a big old spider.
Oh boy.
Spider time.
Brain of spider!
What a big surprise.
I hope for your sake you got something inside that big body of yours.
Oh gosh.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, he's like a spider.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Got it.
Wait, so it was...
Oh
gosh.
I don't want to get close to him.
And I can't see anything.
Okay.
That's really cool.
Oh, there is a dodge!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Yeah, stay over there.
Stay trapped in there, buddy.
Oh, I'm gonna die, aren't I?
I'm gonna die real.
Devil trigger to heal?
Okay.
This guy is like stuck in the wall, actually.
Oh my god.
I lived.
Somehow.
I'm not even doing anything to him.
I think I hit him once.
Are you gonna come out of there?
Taunt?
Uh oh, he's getting unstuck.
I'm so scared.
What happens when I run out of yellow orbs?
What does that mean?
Do I have to start again from the beginning of the game?
I'm so scared.
Just a level.
Okay.
Oh, we are all the way back here.
Oh, just kidding.
We are all the way back here.
The game isn't that cruel.
You can never tell with these older games, right?
Wait, so how did I... Hold on.
How did I dodge again?
No, it was...
I was holding something and I was able to dodge.
Like dodge roll.
I didn't mean to use that.
Lock on.
That's what I did.
But it's still jumping.
Backflip.
R1 side jump.
Oh my god.
So this actually...
Okay, okay.
Jump has iframes too.
Does it?
I hope I didn't just waste my devil trigger.
Can I skip cutscenes?
Oh, I can.
Awesome.
Get in the wall.
Get in the wall, spider.
Oh my god.
Jump away.
Okay, yeah.
He is in the wall.
I can't tell when he is about to do what attack, you know?
Can I get his behind?
No!
You are so fast!
Oh my gosh.
These parts are so...
Jump Dante.
Pretend it's Elden Ring.
Okay, I'll pretend it's a game I've never played before.
Good idea.
Good plan.
Oh my gosh.
That was so close.
I can't tell when he is about to do the...
Oh my gosh.
Just gonna run around.
The trees really get me.
They are too sexy.
Too sexy trees.
They are so fast!
Oh my gosh!
They are so...
Those ones are so fast.
They get me every time.
Oh my gosh.
Save.
Can I save here?
Oh wait.
Save.
I don't even know if this will do anything.
Let's try.
Turn the stinger control...
It's R1 left stick.
In whatever direction Dante is facing.
Plus melee button.
OK.
Hold on.
So R1 left stick.
Melee.
Like that?
What?
There is a moves list in the menu.
I'm moving forward.
Wait.
Like that!
Like that?
OK.
So it's...
It's only...
OK.
So if I'm looking this way...
I have to be pressing right.
OK.
So I can't be...
Forward.
OK.
So it wouldn't be...
It would be this way.
No.
It wouldn't...
Sometimes it's a little confusing.
Wait.
OK.
You're looking this way.
I think the key is to kind of...
Start walking a direction.
Hold and then...
Like if I'm walking this way and then I hold...
I can get it.
You know what I mean?
And I don't have to change...
I don't have to change stick directions.
Yeah.
OK.
Try the opposite direction.
Wait.
What do you mean the opposite direction?
Try R1 back melee.
Like that?
Wait.
Did I just do it?
Ah.
That's...
That's a launcher.
What does that mean?
It launches enemies.
OK.
Holding the attack button.
Nothing.
Just draw some.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
OK.
Let's try...
Wait.
I want to try one more time.
OK.
For the
first time just now.
Thank you.
Thank you for the tank.
Yippee!
I'm a one trick pony you guys.
At least... Wait.
Did I go out the wrong way?
At least you know if I learn something I apply it.
And then I... Stop bullying him.
I apply it and then I use it.
I don't know.
Yippee!
Oh my god.
DMC survive an encounter with Phantom.
That's me.
Thank you.
How did I get worse?
What do you mean you can't just spam one attack and make it?
That should have... I did it so fast.
What are you talking about?
No style.
Who needs style when you clear the mission?
No style points.
So sad.
Guys, I'm starting to get so hungry.
Display one strength to the lion and open the path.
Acquire the melancholy soul.
OK.
Wait, can I power up?
Thanks for the super chat!
Probably didn't notice, but hitting him with a stinger when he's about to shoot a fireball from his mouth can...
I know!
I did notice.
That's why I didn't jump away when he was powering up that fire attack.
That's why I was just like...
I did notice.
Oh no, I can't buy anything else.
Any extra?
I can buy a blue orb!
I'm gonna buy it.
Yeah, I did it two times.
I did, I did, I did, I did.
I noticed, I noticed, I noticed.
Alright, mission start baby.
Blue orb time.
Where?
Oh, it was down here.
I understand now.
What?
Uh oh.
No!
Run Dante!
Dante just run.
Just run Dante.
Run and jump Dante.
Hide Dante!
Did I go to the wrong room?
Is he gonna be out there?
The spider got it's revenge.
Please be gone.
Oh my god.
Die,
die, die.
Alright, everything is destroyed.
Stupid spider.
It's just ruining the whole building.
Worst enemy, you think so?
Okay lion, I'm here to prove my worth.
There is an immense power that will not allow anyone to get closer.
Before I can confront the lion, I'll need a sign.
Shall I use the pride of lion?
Yes.
Here sleeps the gatekeeper.
Magical destruction will awaken him.
Guns seem kind of magical to me, but you know...
Here we go.
He ended me instantly.
No way!
I...I...
He...yes.
He killed me instantly.
Start game at this data?
Yes.
Oh my gosh!
I have to do the spider again.
That one gets me every time!
Wait, Dante!
We can't keep taking hits, Dante!
Dante, please!
Okay.
Alright, he's gone, right?
I'm just gonna run from you.
I don't have time to deal with you right now.
Okay.
This guy, like, instantly takes me out.
The enemy's name is called Psycho Siren.
It's pretty good.
This guy is your dodge check?
Oh gosh.
So if I jump away, it's like the same.
But he, like, instantly grabs me.
It's so crazy.
Okay.
I'm ready to dodge.
I'm ready.
Ouch!
Ouchie!
Oh my god.
This is gonna kill me, isn't it?
I shouldn't be greedy.
I should only do, like, one hit, shouldn't I?
Oh my god!
Where is he?
Maybe I should keep shooting.
Or maybe I should have sworded it.
Okay.
Should I sword it when it's that far?
Oh my god.
Linto.
How am I supposed to know?
Swordman.
It's my first time playing the game.
How am I supposed to know?
My gosh.
You guys are so mean sometimes.
You're just like, gosh, VTuber.
VTuber, how do you not know the very obvious information that is given to you in the game, VTuber?
How do you not know?
The first time you play this game, how did you not immediately read everything about the game that you need to know?
To understand that... And how did you not memorize every single boss?
VTuber, did you not do your research?
VTuber, I expected more from you.
You are streaming a game that means you obviously know everything about the game, VTuber.
VTuber, I came here and I thought that I would see a perfect fight, VTuber.
How dare you not do your research?
VTuber!
VTuber, you dodged, but when he opened up his body, you didn't know that was... That was... Like, VTuber!
Oh my god.
How?
What?
That's
a...
Oh, did I kill him?
No.
Oh, I think I killed him.
Yippee!
Charge!
Do you have any goods for me?
Nothing?
Oh.
Yippee!
Let's keep going.
Oh, wrong button.
Oh my gosh.
VTuber, you did it!
I did!
Thank you!
VTuber, why did you learn so fast, VTuber?
Do I just keep going up?
There was stuff downstairs though, wasn't there?
Wasn't there stuff down?
I want to go down instead of going up.
I want to.
Or maybe I don't want to go down.
It looks kind of deep.
Nevermind.
We do not want to go down.
Or wait, what's over here?
It's a circle.
I want to go down.
No, I do not.
Oh my gosh, you scared me.
It said... OK, the mission was to find some sort of statue, right?
So I'm going to keep going up.
Is this a statue?
There is something written.
The sword is the key to freeing the soul.
The key resides at the highest place.
My sword.
Oh my goodness.
Can I jump over here?
VTuber, why did you not get all the orbs in the level?
I know.
And the worst, I'm sorry.
It's a mirror.
It's me.
It's a statue of a female with a melancholic expression.
And she's sucking on that egg.
There is an opening to place something.
A sword.
I think.
I love watching videos where they go behind the scenes of games and everything.
Because you learn how they do mirror effects and things like that.
Or like how they make lighting.
They'll just put a block behind something.
Or like a lighter block behind another block to make it seem like it's glowing or something.
You know, things like that.
Sometimes they just make another room.
Yeah, it's so interesting.
Boundary break.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
An emblem of a sun is engraved.
There's something written beneath it.
The brightness of the guiding light will scorch you.
Only those who can bear the light can open the new path.
There are documents here that were probably used for diplomacy.
What?
With the neighboring country.
So why?
Where did my mom go?
Where is my hot mom?
Hot mom, where are you?
Question.
If this thing is here, is this a safe room?
Is it a safe room if this thing is here?
Holy water.
I can get another orb.
Yes?
Oh, cool.
She died.
Then who was that lady?
I can buy the air raid, you guys.
Become airborne and be capable of performing aerial electrocution?
I don't know.
Maybe I should save up for stinger level 2.
Even though I didn't use it at all.
I think I'll save up for stinger level 2.
I think so.
I'll save up, I'll save up.
I think I can destroy the bed.
This is a fancy room, isn't it?
Hot dog.
Okay.
It's sealed shut by immense power.
Alright, puzzle time.
There was that area with the guy... Okay, wait.
It says I need to get... What was the mission?
Mission.
Display... Okay.
Acquire the melancholy soul.
That's what we're trying to do here.
How do I insert?
There's an opening to place something.
Is it not my sword?
I was just hopping around.
My sword is too thick.
There's more of them.
I see them down there.
Can I just... 1, 2, hit.
1, 2, 3.
Chat, she knows this is supposed to be Resident Evil 4, right?
Yes.
Yes, I know.
Please.
I know.
Wait.
Was this supposed to be Resident Evil 4?
You might want to tell me one more time.
To make it really stick in there.
My old noggin is kind of old, you know.
Next you're going to tell me that Jaeger means hunter in German.
Did you know this is supposed to be DMC1?
Minto, this is supposed to be Resident Evil 4.
No.
Am I supp...
Why did you
teleport like that?
What if I... You know what?
I'm going to rewrite history.
It was actually supposed to be Resident Evil 3.
How about that?
How about them apples?
You didn't expect that, huh?
Ok, wait.
Am I supposed to...
Ok, I need to go find the sword.
The only thing that I know about the souls... Hold on.
I'm going up to the very top.
What did it say again up here?
We're two hours into this stream.
We're out of trivia.
There's something written.
The sword is the key to freeing the soul.
Yeah.
The key resides at the highest place.
The highest place.
Here?
How do I go any higher?
The highest place.
I'm on the fifth floor.
I'm at the highest place.
Wait.
Ok, I'm scared to jump, but I'm going to try.
Is this an elevator that will go up?
Death sentence.
A decorative sword used for rituals.
It cannot be used as a weapon.
I want to go... I was going to say I want to go down.
What's this door?
Sealed shut by immense power.
There's something written.
This path will open with a guiding soul.
Wait, what's up here though?
That's metal.
You like that?
I did that aerial thing.
Stairs are blocked off so I can't go any further this way.
Gosh, it makes me dizzy though.
Hi!
Alright, let's go up.
I left during spider.
Why did you leave, Tiaro?
How dare you!
I did good.
Right chat?
Everybody say... Minto did it.
She's so smart.
Death sentence, yes.
Oh god!
Melancholy soul.
An ornament resembling a soul.
When activated, it loses its power over time.
Uh oh.
What's happening?
Is it my reflection?
Don't trust anybody, not even yourself!
Dante, turn around!
Oh my god.
I'm evil Dante.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, me!
I'm so sexy!
Nevermind!
Actually...
Dad?
Wait...
Isn't that the guy?
Oh snap!
Isn't that the guy with the horns at the very beginning?
Or am I crazy?
Oh, bye!
Not Sparta.
Oh, I look just like him.
What did this say again?
The brightness of the guiding light will scorch you.
Only those who bear the light can open it.
I'm guessing I go... Oh, should I have saved?
Let's do that real quick.
Cool.
Ouch!
Oh my gosh, it can hurt me.
I learned.
Oh, smiley face.
OK, I won't look, I won't look.
Thanks guys!
Oh my gosh.
This is sword fight, huh?
I learned this!
Ouchie!
Ouch!
OK.
I need to dodge that faster.
Stop parrying me!
Stop it!
Ouch!
Oh my god!
OK, I got greedy you guys.
It's my fault.
I got greedy.
It's OK.
Wait, from the start?
Secret?
Wait, defeat 100 phantom babies.
What the hell is a phantom baby?
Wait, what?
Secret.
I did save!
What's the matter baby?
Nothing much.
What's the matter with you?
Um, phantom babies.
You know what, I'll try... What is...
Oh my god.
It's these guys.
I have to get... Oh my gosh.
Destroy!
I'm only halfway there.
Where is the rest of them?
Oh, I'll go this way.
Destroy!
These are little random spiders or phantom babies!
Uh oh, I'm not gonna make it.
OK,
put me out of my misery, OK?
I know I didn't make it, but stop the mission.
So close.
Can I redo it?
Gotta leave the room.
OK.
Wait, I came from here.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Alright, let's try again.
What's like a good... What's a good strat for this?
I don't know.
I feel like one at a time is too...
OK,
wait, hold on.
I have a good idea.
Where are they?
Where are the matter babies?
Oh, here they are.
Oh, maybe that wasn't such a... That didn't go as well in my head as I thought.
OK, it doesn't do anything actually.
Oh, it kinda does.
OK, I got a single matter baby.
Phantom baby.
My bad.
Hold on.
Wait.
How many did I kill?
How many did I get?
Gun?
I don't think it works as well.
78!
But, guys, look at all the... Wait, you guys, this is easy.
You guys, this is so... Oh, get the pistols.
Yeah.
This is such an easy way to farm.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
But this is kind of awesome.
Yeah.
Wait, this is...
This is the perfect way to farm the rorbs.
Yeah!
OK, hold on.
Oh, wrong way.
There we go.
Weapon.
Handgun.
Equip.
Yes.
Squish and walk.
Squish and shoot.
Squish with feet and shoot with gun.
Always be shooting.
Always be shooting and squishing.
Shooting and squishing.
Did I do it?
Wait, I should have just kept failing so I could farm it over and over again.
Honestly, this is such a good way to farm for rorbs.
Such a good way to farm for rorbs.
Little spiders.
Where are you?
Anybody else?
Oh.
Right there.
I'll eat every last one.
Of those orbs, not the spiders.
Not actually.
That's not actually a good way to farm.
OK, it's an easy way to farm.
I guess they're all gone.
Nice.
Easy means good.
Complete a secret mission.
Can you keep a secret?
OK.
Let's also change back to my shotgun.
Wait, so I have to do the spider again, right?
He's gonna come out here, I think?
And then I have to... Wait, do I have to do the lion again?
Oh no...
I don't care about the painting!
What?
Phantababy too?
You feed a hundred Phantababy?
Kill all Phantababies!
Kill them dead!
Where's the rest of them?
What do you mean 61?
There's... There was not that many in this room!
Oh, without weapons.
Oh, I didn't read that part.
I definitely didn't read that part.
Wait, we'll go back in.
We'll go back in.
No, no, no.
Not you.
Phantababy too.
Without using any weapons.
This seems impossible.
This seems actually impossible.
Come on Dante, run!
Run and squish!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get all in the middle.
Come here to the middle, little babies.
Come to the middle.
We were so close!
We were so close.
We were like 93.
You failed.
Guys, I'm gonna buy so many upgrades.
And by upgrades I mean... More of that one... What's it called?
Does... Will Devil Trigger count as a weapon?
I guess not.
We have enough for a blue orb!
Blue demon!
Yeah, baby!
We did it!
Kill
them till they're dead.
Nice.
Let's upgrade.
Oh my gosh.
Camera, please.
Please, camera.
Alistar.
Singer level 2!
Wait.
Wait, how... What is the round trip?
Throw the sword like a boomerang.
What's air... Double... Double jump?
I have to pay to double jump.
And there's also Vortex level 1.
Damage enemies with an intense spinning body attack.
Should we get Stinger level 2 and then save up for Air Hike?
Air Hike is worth it.
Stinger and then... Okay, let's try it.
Nice.
Alright.
It's a lot to save up, but I believe in us.
I believe in us.
I'm so salty that we have to redo...
That we have to redo the lion.
I'm so salty about that.
Secret mission clear!
Baby!
Oh my gosh, she's so sexy.
Sorry, Minto.
That's okay.
Is it because I'm out of...
Oh my god.
Is it because I'm out of yellow orbs?
Is that why?
Do you want to be backseated on how to find secret missions?
No, because I don't plan on 100%ing the game or anything like that.
So I don't want to always be feeling like I'm pressured to find the secret missions.
But thanks for asking.
Yellow orbs are checkpoints.
Yeah, it's fun to find the surprise, right?
So if I...
If I die again, which I feel like I will, I'll have to...
I'll have to...
Well, I have to do the secret missions again though.
Okay, here we go guys.
Here we go.
I'm ready to dodge.
I don't have to do them again because I saved.
Where is he?
I know it's a lion and I called it a dog.
Okay.
What just happened?
Was that a suicide bomb?
I think so.
What just happened?
Wait, I want to...
They do that sometimes.
No way.
Alright.
I know what I have to do.
Maybe... Actually, let's just jump to the bottom.
Let's just go.
Let's just go where we need to go, alright?
Instead of going all the way to the top.
When it has 1 HP, they become bombs.
Oh, so I like really got him low health.
The guy is like frozen down.
Let's go down the stairs so I don't get ambushed by this guy.
I don't think saving is going to do anything.
Save first?
It's not going to do anything though, right?
It doesn't... I don't have any more orbs.
But will it... Oh wait, actually.
Will saving keep my... Will saving keep my rorbs?
It will save your rorbs.
It will!
Save orbs, progress, nothing else.
I think that's somewhat worth it though.
I want to buy the yellow orb.
Oh man, why did I buy this thing or two?
I'm going to eat a snack.
I hope it's OK guys.
I have some things called cheeza.
Wait, this part was just a cutscene, right?
I didn't have to fight.
No, it was just a cutscene.
I got these in Japan.
My snacks were in Japan.
Don't be greedy.
Mint, don't be greedy.
I'm dead.
But I need food for energy.
Recovery star is a healing item.
Oh...
Oh,
smiley, smiley.
No spoilers in the chat, you guys.
No spoilers, please.
Is there anything over here?
I don't think so.
OK.
Time to...
Beat daddy.
Oh gosh, I forgot about that thing.
OK.
A better singer.
Are you sure this is not my dad?
It looks just like him.
What was his name?
Oh my god, Sparta.
Oh my gosh.
Oh gosh.
Ouch!
Oh my god, he can do the same thing as me?
That kind of sucks.
Oh my gosh.
That was so close.
What the hell, Mint?
Can I shoot him, actually?
No, no, no.
Oh god, guys, I don't think I'm gonna make it.
Shoot.
No.
This is so bad.
Wait, what was this?
Vital Star.
Use it?
Yeah.
Oh, OK.
It takes a lot of hits.
Ah, shit, shit, shit.
No, no, no.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Oh my god, please.
Dante, what the fuck are you doing?
Why were you, like, playing hopscotch on the top of the thing?
Please!
Dante!
Dante, Dante, Dante.
Oh, shoot.
What the hell?
I didn't mean to do that.
Oh my god.
I guess it saved me, though.
She's so beefy!
Beefy!
What the?
Oh, you're making me parkour?
How do I get up there?
Wait.
I'm too small.
Oh, I see.
Oh, OK.
OK, hold on.
I'm a little slow.
Hold on.
OK, then I go up here.
And then I...
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no.
Please, why don't I have any iframes or anything?
Oh, gosh.
Oh my god.
No, no!
What does DT mean?
Oh, double trigger!
Double trigger?
DT heals!
I forgot.
It's my fault.
I know, I forgot.
Oh, gosh.
It's so much that I fall all the way back.
Oh, come on.
I jumped.
I jumped!
Alright, let's just...
OK.
Rage quit.
Hey, where is the guy that usually comes out?
Oh, that's why.
Oh, I don't care about you.
I would much rather deal with one scissor ghost than 15 puppets.
Doesn't jumping have iframes in this game?
People are saying that.
Wait, what's my health?
Oh, I still have the vital star which is good.
My health is not great.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Joy!
Thank you for the 50 gifted.
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Oh, magic.
That's right.
I have to destroy it.
OK, here we go!
Here we go!
Once again...
Oh my gosh.
Oh
shoot!
I didn't see where he was.
No, my health!
We did it!
Oh
my gosh.
The game is like in love with me now.
Real.
Joy!
Thank you for the pink dodo!
Thank you!
I joined at the seagull moment of the stream.
Oh shoot.
No!
Don't hurt me!
Dang it.
I have to do it all over again.
I didn't know it was possible to miss that jump.
I'll be honest.
You know when Squidward tells Spongebob about the hash slinging slasher and he just does the same screen ten times in a row?
That's what you sound like.
No, but I'm not at full health.
This is so bad you guys.
I'm not at my Optimus Prime.
What do I do?
I'm gonna die.
Oh gosh, just win.
DT and you'll be good.
OK.
DT.
Stinger spam.
Yes.
Can I skip these?
No.
OK.
These ones are like in game.
I can skip this.
Alright.
OK.
We got so close before you guys.
We were so close.
There's orbs on the bed.
Oh shoot.
I forgot about getting them again.
Can I get... Wait.
Do I have any water left in here?
I do.
Save.
Yeah, let's save so I can save my orbs.
Saving the rorbs.
Is there a pha... OK.
Don't tell me where it is because obviously I can't get to it now.
But was there a Phantom Baby 3?
Was there a third Phantom Baby?
Solidus Phantom Baby?
Yes!
Oh my god.
Wait, am I getting one guide?
I can't tell.
Monthly streamer tax paid.
Medic, thank you!
Oh no.
Is the third Phantom Baby in the room with us?
I don't know.
You're the Phantom Baby.
Your powers are still young, but one day they'll call you the drink.
Is it because I'm a cold glass of water?
Les Enfants Arachnids?
OK, I'm stalling.
I'm stalling.
I don't want to skip this because...
I want the... I want to have my dodge.
Oh
my gosh.
So unfair!
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
No, guys, this is not the run.
No, I'm already... I'm already...
I'm already... I'm not doing so hot.
I'm already messing up.
Nothing personal, kid.
He literally did that to me!
What?
Oh shit.
Wait.
I'm gonna use it.
Even though I Devil Triggered, I'm gonna use it.
No,
no, no.
Jump, jump, jump.
Oh my god.
How did he...
Stinger spam!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Wait, I'm healing while I'm like... I thought I only healed while I took hits.
Or while I was hitting him, but... OK.
Yeah!
Oh my god, we got him.
Piss fight.
OK.
We hate swords now.
Grab his hair.
Kiss him.
Oh my god.
It's the Devil Tear.
The Devil that cried.
He made the tear.
He's going sicko mode.
I knew I was right to believe in you.
Thank you!
Mission clear, baby!
Survive an encounter with Nello Angelo.
It's OK, we're alright guys.
D!
D for damn!
That girl's got moves!
D for Devil May Cry.
Obviously.
Boss bonus.
Save, please let me save.
We're only on mission 5.
Go to the destination before the power of the melancholy soul fades away.
To the... Minto Gaming!
D for do better next time.
Next mission is annoying.
Is it a timed mission?
There's only 23 missions.
Yeah!
5, 10, 15, 20.
Oh, I guess...
25.
Wait.
So we're like... Oh, OK.
It is...
But I can just drop to the bottom, right?
Let me just try it.
Let's just try it and see before I try and buy...
Melancholy soul!
Yes, that's you.
Oh no.
No!
Don't go away!
Oh my gosh, that was so close.
Are these guys gonna end up becoming a regular enemy?
How icky.
If so...
Oh my god, please.
He has 1 HP, I think.
Oh my god.
You ass.
OK.
How do I get up there?
And then...
Nope.
How did I get up there?
How did I... Oh shoot.
Wait.
I did it before.
No.
Oh no.
Wait.
Oh god.
From here maybe?
What the hell?
Stinger?
Dante?
Dante!
Just a second.
From here?
I can't jump.
There is a ceiling.
Maybe from here?
Oh.
Nope.
I'm not panicking.
You're panicking.
You're the one typing in all caps in my chat.
Oh here it is.
Let's go there.
What
if I just run?
See guys?
I made it.
B!
I got a B.
For believe in Minto.
Duh.
B for believe.
Spieve.
Evil of the waterways.
Defeat the light guardian... Oh sorry.
The evil guardian and acquire the guiding light.
That's what will be... That's what the sun said.
Evil... Is this a boss fight?
Another boss fight?
Okay.
We're waiting for the... We're waiting for... What was it on here?
It won't even let me go past stinger level 2.
Do I have to like unlock it?
Okay.
I gotta save up for the air hike.
Sub boss and it's annoying as shadow.
Got it.
The shadow of the pupper.
The little dog.
Creepy.
Which way...
Shall I go...
Oh!
Okay!
Thanks for the hurricane.
I've been without running water for two days now.
Binary!
I'm getting sticky but I think my cat respects me more now.
I'm glad you're safe though.
I'm glad you're safe.
You and your kitty.
Oh.
Wait, do I need this?
What's my health at?
Oh!
I'll take it.
Oh, what's this?
It's raining rorbs.
I'm gonna save after that.
Why does it zoom in after every... I thought it was about to explode because it kept zooming in on me.
I was like, I'm about to die.
It's a trap.
It's a secret.
It's like...
I wasn't supposed to be doing this.
Can I go into the hole?
I can jump on top of it.
I'm exploring for now, guys.
I know there's a door there in case you're like, hey, my dog!
Go through the door.
Alright.
Yeah, stay safe though.
Oh, the door is locked up.
Rusty.
It's always a rusty key.
Why doesn't this place take care of their keys?
What are these?
That's wood.
Are things gonna start coming out of the holes?
Oh boy.
Oh wow.
There's a lot of holes in this room.
Oh, is this the guy?
Okay.
That looks like a rusty key.
I'm styling.
How do I...
Grab it, Dante.
Grab it.
Dante?
Am I supposed to press B?
Just...
That doesn't work.
Oh, there we go.
I just have to get closer.
The key is rusty.
Who would have thought?
Gross!
The devil is crying.
I'm crying right now.
Ew!
Oh
my gosh.
Gross!
Come down here, you coward!
I think I got him.
Ew, they even turned into maggots.
Nice.
Matara's cousins.
I wondered why there wasn't anything in here before.
Nice.
At least they heal.
Okay, rusty key time.
Wait, is there more?
No.
Alright, before we go in here...
Oh, wrong.
Save the game.
Save.
Complete.
Let's go.
We use the rusty key.
Okay.
That looks...
That looks like it could be blown up.
They dropped a fair amount of rorbs.
Awesome.
My favorite thing to eat.
Rorbs.
Video games made me think...
That I would be going into sewers way more in my life.
You don't go into sewers?
I think you're the weird one.
All my homies go into sewers.
What are these?
This looks like something I shouldn't stand in the middle of.
I'm going to go around it.
Just kidding.
It's the guy!
He's got big ol' scissors.
Let's try... I don't even know what the strat is here.
Just dodge, I guess?
I'm going to die.
Shit.
I could double trigger again.
I was trying to earlier, but it wouldn't let me.
It wasn't recharged.
I did try though.
I wasn't not trying to double trigger.
But now I know I can't also hit him with...
Or I could hit him with my sword, but it was way easier to just shoot him.
Using pistol?
Best against him?
Oh, is it?
Okay, let's try that.
Actually, it probably would be good against the...
The little flies too, huh?
Maybe, because they're faster, right?
Let's try it.
Ebony and ivory!
Oh, I got this already.
We know you tried, it's just that Summachat forgot DT needs at least 3 full symbols to be activated.
And I think it happened like right at the end, so...
That's okay, I can get more stuff.
Oh wait, before we do that...
Can I farm here?
I'm meat, the rorbs!
I'm hungry for the rorbs!
I'm hungry, I'm starving for the rorbs!
We're doing good though.
Thank you!
Taunting can raise... Taunting can raise devil trigger?
Really?
I
know I shouldn't only be using my gun.
Or did I get him?
Oh my god!
Die!
The dude was zooming.
How did I get there?
Who ate a key?
Oh my gosh!
Are they riding on top of each other?
What do you mean?
Duh!
It's such a cool move!
What are you talking about?
There's a guy on the wall!
Look at them go!
Where is he?
I saw one last guy.
Just kidding, I didn't see one last guy.
I am a liar.
Always save to keep the rorbs.
How many rorbs am I at anyway?
Let's see.
Oh!
1,300.
We're gonna be so close...
to...
4,000.
Any day now.
We're gonna be at 4,000 any day now guys.
I'll get double jump real.
Should I save those for after the fight?
Chewing through this game way better than most I've seen.
I'm only on mission 6.
And it's been 3 hours.
Wait, I'm just...
Ok, here we go.
Oh gosh!
Oh shoot!
Shoot!
I tried to dodge!
Oh my gosh!
Move out of the way Dante!
Oh my gosh, it's so unfair!
Oh my god, please.
Ok, so when he swings I need to jump.
Guys, I don't think this is it.
Unless I... Oh no, I can't jump!
Oh my god.
Dies of cringe.
So true.
It's ok.
Every time I grow stronger and also get more orbs.
So we're closer to the air hike, which I don't...
I don't even know if that would be worth it in this battle.
This battle is so tight.
Why is it so tight?
Air hike?
Oh, wrong way.
Super here for your battlemate training arc.
Thank you!
Freezing?
What did I say?
Gross!
I hate these eyes!
Oh my god.
Oh, what the hell?
What is going... Why am I getting... Why am I taking so much damage?
Fine, I'll blow you up!
Fine, is that what you wanted?
Oh my gosh.
I was not this bad at these guys before.
Oh my god.
What happened?
I'm regressing.
I saw him on the...
Come here.
Actually, I'll just do that.
Oh man!
Different gun.
Actually, the shotgun is kind of good against them.
Can I farm health?
Doesn't seem to be the case.
Six months?
Thanks for sticking around me though!
Superion, thank you!
Thanks for sticking around as well for six whole months.
I really appreciate it.
I see him.
Sniped.
Wait, is there anyone else?
I think that was the only guy.
It's been a wonderful half a year for me too.
Thank you for the signal!
Welcome to the membership!
Evan, thank you for six months.
Thank you guys!
My health is not...
But we can get health here.
At least.
Oh wait, I forgot to save.
I'm here for break stuff and Mata.
Go get them ghosts!
You got this!
Thank you!
From Mata.
Tell her she's really stinky.
Break stuff.
There may be a break stuff performance in the future.
In the near future even.
OK, so next gun.
Other gun, other gun.
Happy six months with me dog!
Get crowded!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
OK.
I'll pack a change.
Six months party.
Suddenly it's a six months party.
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Alright.
I'm starting to get sleepy.
So I think after, once we beat this guy, hopefully we beat him soon.
Hopefully.
Hopefully we beat him soon.
You guys weren't kidding when he's annoying.
When it's lower ground he can melee it.
Oh my gosh!
Ouch!
Oh my god.
Guys, this is not the run.
Guys, this is... Oh my god.
You guys, this is so bad.
What the fuck?
What is happening?
I give up.
Why?
This run is so cursed.
First it was the bugs, now it's this guy.
What the hell?
I'm so annoyed right now.
I was...
Oh my gosh.
I keep going the wrong way.
I was so bad through this whole run.
Maybe it's because I'm hungry.
That's why I'm regressing.
Ok.
That is equipped now, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
6 months part wait.
DMC1 experience?
Ok.
Thank you for being here, Minto.
Thank you!
Get out of here.
I'm just gonna start blasting away, baby.
Oh my gosh.
Ok, ok, ok.
Oh, I did it.
Minto playing hollow cure out here.
I wish I was playing hollow cure.
I play... I try to play a little bit everyday.
Wait, where is my... I lost the glorb.
No!
It's ok.
We'll get a new one.
Spam those bullets like tuba.
Take
their butts down.
Take their butts down.
I don't realize I'm killing them.
Half a year really flew by.
I know.
I can't believe half a year.
It's been only... It's half a year since I opened memberships.
I don't remember.
I had to wait a bit before I got memberships, right?
What's my health at?
Oh, we're full.
Ok.
Alright.
I'm nervous.
Look at him go.
I found out how to send one of these.
Go, mate!
Thanks, Scorcher!
Hitting his head with a sword deals more damage.
If I can get in there.
Alright.
I'm sleepy-eepy.
For those wondering, too...
Tomorrow...
Tomorrow, Snake Eater will not happen.
I'm gonna reschedule it.
Sorry.
Because my schedule for VMuse is a little crazy.
Ok.
I'll post about it, though.
I'll post the waiting room so you guys know in advance, too.
When it will be instead.
How am I supposed to avoid this?
Go
in the wall, you cheater!
Double trigger!
Why won't it let me?
Please, please, Taka.
Why won't it let me do it?
My double trigger was on 3!
It wasn't fully.
It looks so close, too.
Ok,
guys.
One more try.
I do this every time.
One more try and then I'm gonna call it.
We'll do it next time.
Because I really am starting to get sleepy.
Wait, what do I have on?
I don't feel confident using my sword in it.
Because it's hard to get him.
Because he's flying.
Maybe if I try with these guys.
Because they're also flying around.
But it's such a tight spot that I don't feel confident using my sword with him.
You know?
I'd rather just...
Why are you doing that?
Ouch!
Stop it!
Why are you so beefy this one time?
Guns deal too low damage?
Is that really the case?
Holy shoot!
That was so awesome.
Combo extenders not damage dealers.
What do I hear?
Is it behind me?
Okay, I'll try to use my sword more this time.
At least I'll... I always do this.
At least I'm kind of getting more...
Rorbs, I guess.
What am I at?
1500?
Okay.
We believe in you, man.
Thank you!
Nah, you guys are good.
You guys are...
Being nice.
You're just trying to help out.
I get it.
It's me being stubborn and wanting to use my guns.
It's me being stubborn and wanting to...
Look at how cool...
Why wouldn't I want to use my guns when that's what he does?
Alrighty.
Alright, sword.
Also, let me turn off my fan.
My contacts are starting to dry up.
Oh my gosh.
I decorated my fan earlier with some stickers and I forgot I did so and I looked at it and I was like...
Oh my god.
What's wrong with my fan?
Hold on.
Oh my gosh.
These contacts suck.
I got them...
They're like...
You can't really tell.
Because they're still blue.
But their color contacts...
I don't know.
Can you tell?
Did my eyes look different today?
But their color contacts that I got in Japan...
But like...
They...
They are so awful.
They dry up so quickly.
Yeah, we can tell.
Yeah, you can tell.
So...
Shotgun can do damage.
Wait, but people were telling me before to use these guns instead.
Mental love as always.
But even the other day I was wearing these contacts.
I'm just using them because I'm trying to get rid of them.
Like I was like...
Oh, I paid for them.
I might as well...
I might as well wear them.
And...
I went to the store.
And I rubbed my eye.
And one of them came out!
I was like...
I had to go to the bathroom and put it back in.
And it was barely...
Oh my gosh, it was so dried up.
I could barely put it back in.
I had to go home and immediately take it out.
It was so bad.
Minto has special eyes.
Yeah, it's like an anime girl thing, you know?
Like...
My eyes are so big that contacts don't stay in them very well.
So...
Yeah.
Should I switch to shotgun then?
Maybe.
Maybe if I'm gonna focus more on...
Okay, I'm gonna switch to shotgun.
If I'm gonna try and focus more on the sword...
Because...
Then I won't be like...
Pew, pew, pew!
I'll be like...
Pew!
Look at this.
Dante, hold on.
Turn around, Dante.
Do your thing.
Oh my god, not that hand in the...
Oh my gosh, he's got like...
He's got a...
He's tilting his knee in.
This is like idol posing.
He's so cute.
Okay.
I don't feel like I'm gonna get it because I'm gonna...
Yeah!
Oh shoot.
Oh,
we're already at this phase?
Oh shoot.
No, no, no.
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
No, I'm not even done!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Oh guys, guys.
This is not it.
Okay.
Alright guys, we'll get him next time.
We'll get him next time.
You were so close, I know.
Dang.
It's okay, he's tricky.
He was one hit away from dying, I think.
Should we do it?
You can see how much health this boss has by looking at how many horns he has.
It's kind of hard, he's all over the place.
One more?
Okay, let's do one more.
One more, one more.
One day more.
I feel like if I don't do it now, I'll lose the technique for next time.
I feel like I'll lose the technique.
One day more.
Get him while they're kind of slowed down.
Nice.
This guy is so beefy.
What are you eating?
Why are you always this beefy?
He's so beefy.
Did you say you're old and clunky?
What do you mean?
Why are you insulting me?
Just because I'm insulting... I'm not insulting you, why are you insulting me?
What did I do to you?
What did I do to you to deserve this?
Where's the other guy?
I thought I saw him.
Oh, I think I got him.
Wait, is there anymore down here?
No?
OK.
Who even said that?
I need to call you out by name.
Where are you?
Mean!
Mean mugger!
You are mean!
Mean!
You're real quiet now, huh?
You're real quiet now.
Oh, oopsie.
It's not even an apology!
Just oops.
Actually, you know what?
I respect that even more.
You're not sorry that you got caught.
You're just like, nah, I said it, and I meant it, and I'm not sorry.
Man thought he wouldn't be called out.
Tehepero moment, real.
Oopsie, tehepero.
No!
I was AFK.
Did she pass the enemy?
Yes!
Yeah.
I did.
Wait, how many?
OK, still at 1500.
This sucks.
Show them who's the real boss these six months.
You better not have left.
You have to watch every single stream now.
We're just farming rorbs.
I don't think... This is like the worst way to farm them.
They give you barely any.
I want to go back to the phantom babies.
They gave me a ton of rorbs.
I would get a hundred from them.
Murphy, thanks for the five cup dead!
OK, alright, let's do this.
One day more.
OK.
Oh my god, we did it!
The Guiding Light!
Akiba shines in Ardour.
Ardour?
Ardour.
It slowly drains the power of the...
Wait.
Yippee!
What did I get?
Give me a high grade.
The Seabird can do it.
That's how it's done, boss.
Ducky, thanks for the five cup dead!
All it took was one more.
We did it, guys.
We did it.
Oh, I'm so proud of us.
Yay!
OK.
I'm gonna click next mission, but this will be for...
Mission 7.
Holding the key of Ardour.
Return to the bedroom.
Oh my gosh.
Buy me dinner first.
Before the Guiding Light absorbs all of your vitality.
This is another timed mission, right?
No, no!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Maybe I should just run for it.
Maybe I can do it.
But if I power up...
If I get another blue orb...
Maybe I should do this.
Seito!
Thanks for the five gifted!
It's not as hard as it sounds.
Just run?
OK.
Let's do this one.
Sorry.
Because it's not a boss...
Because it's just a running thing...
Alright, I'm gonna get a blue orb.
OK.
Alright.
Let's go.
Mission... Start!
Runnin', runnin', runnin', runnin', runnin' Runnin', runnin', runnin', runnin' Runnin', runnin', runnin', runnin' Runnin', runnin', runnin' Ignore the green blobs.
Ignore them.
Oh my gosh.
Are you kidding me?
How did you get down here?
Please.
Seriously.
Oh my god.
Oh, heckin' way.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Runnin', runnin', runnin' Oh.
See.
No, wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is not the door I needed to go to.
Cyclops?
Wait, I don't want to...
Let me out of this secret mission.
Into their mutual death.
How do I get out?
Oh my god.
Oh, is this room?
Wait, I'm gonna die in here.
Please.
Let me out.
Just run, Dante, run.
Oh gosh.
Where's the... Oh, over here.
Oh my god.
Down here, down here, down here.
Oh, wait.
I have to...
I have to kill them.
I think.
Oh god.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
These guys suck.
Wait.
Please.
I'm gonna die here.
Oh, yes, thank you.
Thank you, Digger.
Devil trigger, devil trigger.
Thank you.
No, I do have to fight because the door was blocked.
Oh my god, I'm not gonna make it though.
I'm actually... I don't know if I'm gonna make it for real.
Oh, I've lost... I've missed one.
It's ok.
Bothersome flies.
Ok, run.
Run, Dante, run!
Ok, we made it.
Here.
Use the guiding light.
Yes!
I like this music.
I like how you can just hear random music.
Yippee!
I got an A.
B.
Yay!
Yippee!
I think actually buying that other blueberry helped.
I'm Dante.
I think buying that other blueberry helped.
Alright.
Wait, did I do it?
Yes.
Ok, there we go.
Ok, just kidding.
Alright, next mission.
Let's see what the next mission is before I...
Wait, what is this?
I thought Dante had long hair for a second.
The legendary knight returns!
Activate the mechanism and escape from the rooftop.
Let's do that.
I feel like if I don't stop here, I'm never going to stop.
If I don't stop here, I'm never going to stop.
So next time...
Next week we will do mission 8 and we'll see how far we get from there.
There's no good stopping point.
Yeah, otherwise I'll just keep going and going and going.
Maybe next week.
I don't know.
Maybe I can do an endurance.
I'm not sure.
But we'll see.
Not to finish, but just to go longer.
7 missions is about a third of the way through.
Yeah!
Chai Princess, thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I couldn't hear you guys' donos.
This game wrecked me when I was younger.
Also, good luck at VMuse.
I bought a streaming ticket.
Thank you!
Thank you, YouGamedVtuber.
Hope you keep playing this game, Rinto.
I will, of course.
I'm having a lot of fun.
Thank you!
None of us are bored at our Optimus Prime, Rinto.
Thank you guys for the help, too.
I guess I'm fine to quit, right?
Because I'll just load from where I saved.
Don't forget Game Mechanics, VTuber.
I can't even speak today.
I will try not to forget Game Mechanics.
I will try not to forget.
But yeah, this was fun.
Thank you guys.
Devil may sleep now.
Yeah.
Devil didn't cry.
Devil may sleep.
1 third of the game in one sitting is great for first DMC.
You're doing fantastic, VTuber.
Aww, you guys beat it?
Oh my gosh.
You guys are being so nice to me today.
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Devil may snooze.
I hope you guys have a good snooze.
Have a good rest.
And it's the weekend!
Have a good weekend!
We'll finish up Snake Eater probably on Sunday.
Probably.
I'm gonna make a waiting room for Sunday and see how I feel after sleeping some after VMuse.
So, go soon!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
I'm excited that you're enjoying the game.
I'm excited to watch my Kamiyoshi play the series.
Thanks for playing the Resident Evil offshoot game.
Of course.
Bye bye!
Have a good night!
And I will see you guys whenever I stream next, which I'm not quite sure when.
Uday!
Welcome to membership!
Oh my gosh, are you me?
Brick, welcome back!
Thank you!
Stop it.
We're having a good time.
Thanks, couple!
Bye bye, guys!
Bye bye!
Good night!
Thank you!
See you!
Bye bye!